Barbie has gone binary.
Mattel has transformed the world's most famous plastic person...
...into a digital doll...
...with the addition of a computer-enhanced version of its best-selling toy.
Introduced at this year's Toy Fair Convention in New York City,...
...the teched out and decked out darling dubbed the "Barbie Digital Dress Doll".
...is rocking new threads, featuring a touch panel with 114 tricolored LEDs.
A pre-programmed light show of designs and shapes...
...can be displayed on the front of the dress,...
...and its flashing activity can even respond to music.
And if that isn't enough to make you want to drop 50 bucks for a bedazzled Barbie,...
...you can use a stylist to channel your inner Chanel...
...by drawing your own custom designs.
But wait, there's more!
Mattel also showed off the Barbie Digital Makeover Mirror,...
...a kid-sized accessory that incorporates dad's iPad...
...and facial tracking technology,...
...allowing its fashion-forward user to apply virtual makeup.
What's next?
Barbie Borg?
Resistance will be fashionably futile.